a former British police officer has been
sentenced to at least 30 years in prison
for a series of offenses including rape
committed over two decades David Carrick
admitted to the crimes while working
with London's Metropolitan Police
hundreds of officers are now being
investigated Sonia Gallego hasmore
they are the first Port of Call for law
enforcement and prevention of crime in
the UK's Capital with unique
responsibilities and challenges yet a
crisis of confidence has overshadowed
London's Metropolitan Police
some 800 police officers are being
investigated for sexual and domestic
abuse
Revelations of criminals within its
ranks including Wayne cousins who
abducted raped and murdered Sarah
everard as she was walking home nearly
two years ago
and David Carrick who admitted to dozens
of rapes and sexual offenses against 12
women across two decades have shaken
faith in the force policing in the UK
relies on the Public's consent and trust
but that trust has been in Decline over
the past few years especially when it
comes to issues of violence against
women and girls and the continuing
disclosures of members of the force
who've been found guilty of such crimes
is only exposing How deep the problem
runs reports of sexual offenses and
domestic abuse have increased yet
convictions are at historic lows we see
some appalling attitudes of of disbelief
and blame that that you know that
sometimes women report to us and and
that's that obviously causes many to
pull out of of pursuing allegations so
we're not just talking about here about
police officer perpetrators which is
obviously you know absolutely
you know should never happen but also
talking about in it you know policing
which is not giving confidence when Sapp
pajama reported to police she had been
raped and abused by her uncle the
response she says was one of disbelief
when I wanted to show them fresh marks I
had on my body
I said to her like this is where he
lasted to me he burnt my back
I want you to know what he did
she said to me how did she know he did
it
so they didn't even see
and then that was very it was very sad
for me
restoring trust will be a massive
undertaking and in the wake of the
carrot trial an overhaul of the UK's
entire police culture maybe just one
step to restoring some Measure of Faith
in the force Sonic Gallego Al Jazeera
London